hey guys my name is Jess McDonald and
happy may the 4th that star wars day for
any of you who've been living under a
bantha and in the spirit of the day I've
got three awesome Star Wars stories all
ready to go here's the first Xbox one is
celebrating the day by releasing concept
up the controllers that you'll probably
never get your hands on although from
the looks of one of them you might not
want to the for content our controller
images are inspired by c-3po a
stormtrooper Boba Fett and Chewbacca
respectively they look pretty awesome
albeit not the most functional
particularly the Chewbacca one which is
literally covered in hair let me know
which is your favorite personally I'm
partial to the stormtrooper one but it's
probably not useful if you actually want
to shoot straight in your games next up
stills from Star Wars Episode seven the
force awakens have dropped today
alongside new plot details according to
Vanity Fair the force awakens is going
to feature a character called kylo Ren
who looks like an evil Jon Snow and
lives on an ice planet he has snow
troopers doing his bidding and will be
played by Adam driver Lupita Nyong'o is
going to play a CGI character called Maz
Kanata whose alignment is uncertain
although she appears to be some sort of
pirate the force awakens will be out on
December 18 of this year Miley I've got
some star wars battlefront info for you
specifically multiplayer details
battlefront will have 12 multiplayer
maps at launch according to develop a
dice the dev said that this doesn't
include locations from the game's co-op
missions mode as note that more maps
will arrive as DLC later on so far dice
has mentioned maps that will take place
in indoor and hot as well as celeste a
place mentioned in Star Wars lore but
never fully explored some maps will
support the 40 player war for assault
mode while others are designed solely
for close quarters combat battlefront
launches on November 17 let me know down
in the comments which star wars location
you'd like to see incorporated into
battlefront as a multiplayer
Matt and why you can add again spot
where we've got news on John Romero
spot-on paid mods and screams from
kingdom come deliverance that is it from
me today let me know what you cared
about may the 4th be with you and I'll
be back same time tomorrow with
significantly less star wars and use